[Musique]
c'était vraiment vraiment impressionnant
elle a senti les la maison vibrer et
j'ai sorti
j'ai sorti ma chaîne comme je le fais
d'habitude à la même heure et j'ai vu
les voisins
assez panique est en train de me dire
qu'il y avait de la fumée dans le fond
je suis allé voir parce que je sais
qu'il ya pas mal de gens que je connais
et qui habite d'un dans cette rue et
c'est vrai que je suis arrivé j'avais
l'impression d'être sur une scène de
guerre comme on voit à la télé quoi
je me suis dit que vu les commerces là
où c'était ça peut être une bouteille de
gaz du snack à côté à cause de la prise
de feu la chaleur c'est ce que je me
suis dit de suite parce qu'il ya pas mal
de commerces et de snacks ou de petits
restaurants me suis dit c'est peut-être
une cuisine qui a sauté ça aurait pu
très bien pu arriver c'est vrai que sur
le coup c'était un prêtre est
impressionnant